i am a huge fan
of the series and so thankful that
netflix is making a third season and
hopefully many more
um what was it like for you stepping
back on the set for the first time
for season three well
um covid protocols changed a lot
um number one so we could actually shoot
the thing so we've got to
have a lot of rules and regulations in
place that we can actually shoot it um
but you know the scripts are so great
for season three like i'm
you know it's it's it's really such a
joy
to be doing it um
i feel you know very privileged to be a
part of this this show and
uh i think the best thing really is that
you know we're all we're all so
comfortable with each other now
so it feels like we can really hit the
ground running from a creative
standpoint
and we've got the same crew you know
most of the same crew and
um i think we know who these characters
are and who we are playing them and
who you know i think when we work with
each other we're very aware of
of how to react and you know in in these
scenes so
as a family you know i think we're we're
in a great place and it's
it's like we're a good sports team i
suppose when a sports team really finds
that flow
you know and they you know they go on a
winning streak it feels a bit like that
you know
we're very we're very fortunate to have
a very talented
uh cast and and crew did kovid
impact the shooting schedule of season
three were you originally
gonna film it earlier or how did that
affect anything
i'm not sure i think we were actually
supposed to originally shoot a little
bit earlier
um i'm not sure only the only thing the
good thing that
came out of it was it allowed me to
shoot resident evil um because resident
evil was probably originally going to be
a clash but then that
that allowed me to shoot that but um
it was good because it allowed my family
and stuff to come out with me in january
and
and start with them so no yeah it was
i think this is this is a good schedule
we started on uh i've spoken to a lot of
writers and showrunners and they've all
told me that the pandemic while
terrible for the planet and obviously
the worst thing ever
um has actually been good in terms of
the writing process for a lot of movies
and tv shows
because it allowed a lot of people to
get ahead on scripts
and spend more time on the scripts that
they normally wouldn't be able to
and you mentioned already that you were
really happy uh with the writing
um did you get um all 10 scripts already
did you just get some of them
how did that work yeah we've had a fair
chunk yeah we've
uh we've not got all 10 but we've had a
fair chunk and
yeah i think you're right you know i
think you did allow them to have a bit
of extra time on
um because i think we got commissioned
you know in the middle of all this stuff
so
the writers i guess got yeah more of a
head start so
um and that's only allowed them to kind
of like really refine them so the ones
we're getting now are really
special uh i interviewed gerard way
before the first season came out
and he told me that he gave steve an
18-page document
that basically told him everything
including the eight the other graphic
novels that had not been written yet he
like gave steve at all uh gave steve
so how much have you asked steve to be
like hey
so you're gonna tell me everything or
how much are you finding out season by
season no
i'm the opposite man i live i i have to
do everything in the moment i'm kind of
like
episode by episode because i don't want
to know like what's happening like way
in advance
so um i know that some people like need
to know kind of
they want to know everything that's
going to happen whereas i'm kind of the
opposite i'm uh
i wouldn't even look at like episode
four and five until like
done on one two and three so
uh i like to really kind of take my time
with it
uh i believe where are you actually in
the filming process i think i heard that
you
you guys are shooting till september
which is a long shoot
yeah well the kobe protocols mean that
we have like shorter days
um which means that the actual length of
the shoot is going to be a lot longer
um but uh yeah we're
kind of really near the beginning you
know we're not that far into it at the
moment
um so we've got a long way to go but
it's good the thing is
the great thing is the material the work
is amazing so every day on stage
like i say a joy and so much fun looking
backwards i loved season two
i loved the time jump i loved it was
especially the opening episode the
action
and the finale like it's just a great
season but now that you can talk about
it
um because you obviously you can talk
about it before what what did you take
away from season two and what were your
thoughts on the finale um
i loved it i think it's a great setup
for season three
um i i thought that the the show really
sort of
found a groove you know i think it like
what was so great about season two is
that we we'd set up the world in season
one you know and i really feel that
season one was almost like a set
up for the rest of the show isn't we
you're not trying to figure out what
this world is anymore you know who these
characters are you know where they're
they're at in their lives and and then
we can really get things going and
i think towards the end of season two
you really start to just
see what this show is you know and
uh it's it's a great setup for what
what's going to happen in
three um i'm just curious if you could
talk a little bit about uh
uh things that maybe fans fans of the
series
might not realize about the making of
the series is there anything that you
wish
like they knew anything that might
surprise people about the behind the
scenes
um it might surprise people um i mean it
depends what you know about making a tv
show you know
um i think one thing you have to
realize as well is that the the true
genius behind the show
is the writers and steve blackman and
netflix you know
these guys give us i think what
and it probably comes across you know
but they they have this amazing writing
on the page
already like from the from the back
you're reading these scripts you know
this is just gold
and a joy as an actor to do and then
on top of that like steve says you know
always give me like one that's on the on
the script but then feel free to play
you know play around like be creative
see where the scene evolves to um and
that for actors
um you know people might not know that
you know on other shows you don't have
that
that lenience and that kind of creative
uh
flow and allowance and uh they give us
that on this show which is which is
amazing
you know like they um
they don't they don't kind of hold us
back you know we're quite we're quite
free to
try some as long as we give them stuff
on the page which is you know like i say
like so nice to do how does it work with
uh preparing for the action on a show
like this
do you typically have a lot of time for
rehearsals are you learning
moves on the day like how does that work
um it varies really most of the time we
get a pretty decent amount of prep time
especially if it's a big fight you know
like the last season like david who
plays diego he had like a big one
shot you know so he had to you have to
prepare these things and i those big
fights in the
in the uh the underground fighting ring
and stuff so
they're pretty well rehearsed and then
sometimes you know you have moments
where
we're like kind of on the fly and we
like there's a moment that needs to be
added then you've got to like just jump
in and do it and sometimes
they're the best because it it's not
rehearsed or over rehearsed you know you
can just
uh kind of have these little action
moments or like a fall or a stunt or
something
um and i quite enjoy those kind of
moments actually
you never know when you sign on to a
series if it's going to be popular if
people are going to respond to it
um what what was your reaction with
umbrella academy because
right out of the gate it was a big show
and season two was even bigger
so what what's been your reaction to the
reception to the series
i think um gratitude number one that
people actually
really enjoyed you know tuning into it
um because there's always like a
there's a the pressure especially with
like uh source material you know
already had an existing fan base so
there's a responsibility we had to
obviously
serve that audience before everything
else on top of it and actually making
the show something that lots of people
will enjoy not just fans of the comic
um but it kind of blew me away man it
blew me away like i couldn't believe
that
i think sometimes you know a show can
feel good when you're shooting it or
like some of the movie it could feel
good everything feels like it's good
you never really know you never know how
it's going to hit and then
i think why it hit so well was it kind
of hits multiple demographics you know
it's enjoyable for
parents to watch with their kids and i
think a lot of families watched it
together and like couples watch it
together
so it seemed to seem to hit a lot of
notes
and different demographics so more than
anything just
surprised how well it did you know i
think i expected it to do okay i think i
always expected people to
watch it but i was like blown away about
how well i did yeah
actually this is my last thing for fans
of the series
uh what can you tease about season three
or what do you want them to know
if anything i just wanted to know
that if they've loved the first two
seasons
um we've upped the ante like big time
and if um the fun factor is up
um i think the wow factors up um and i
think they're just gonna fall in love
with these characters even more
i really hope so anyway and i think we
just we've just added so many
like more little injections of of juice
into there and
uh yeah i hope it's i hope it's
everything they hope it is